[Musique]
avez vous remarqué à quel point il est
parfois difficile de plonger dans nos
propres vies
on sait qu'il suffit donne pas une voix
intérieure nous parle on le sait
clairement on sait qu'il suffit de se
parler de piocher dans le rythme nos
incertitudes pour trouver les réponses
que nous cherchons les cependant ne le
fait jamais l'esp et comme nous sommes à
ne pas de nos peurs nos doutes nos
complexes et le croyances limitantes et
parfois la vie nous donne un énorme coup
de pied dans les fesses et vous plongez
en dépit de vos résistances
c'est exactement ce qui m'est arrivé un
13 février 2009 et il ne parle en sérère
je me suis retrouvé sur le lit d'hôpital
j'étais passé à sa de l'année le rythme
je ne serai plus parler français je suis
espagnol
mon accent les plus déroutants encore je
ne reconnaissais plus la femme avec
laquelle je vivais depuis huit ans cette
histoire elle avait commencé beaucoup
d'années auparavant presque quinze
membres
à cette époque j'avais une seule
obsession je voulais sur fait les plus
belles femmes au monde et des vallées
les plus belles montagnes avec mon
snowboard et comme c'était nul en sport
fallait pas pouvoir le faire autant de
sportifs de haut niveau
du coup il a bien fallu que je trouve
une excuse pour me faire payer et c'est
exclu ce fut l'entreprise avec 3 ans je
crée ma première entreprise et par la
suite j'ai encore plein d'autres je suis
dans cette magnifique industrie plat
glisse et mon parcours est serti de
succès et je suis dans cette courbe
ascendante et je rentre dans ce que moi
j'appelle la section de rêve mais je
suis vraiment dans mon paradis et un
jour je me suis perdu dans son pack dans
ce paradis et ce rêve que j'avais je les
vends lui j'ai commencé à payer des
jeunes pour le vivre en ma place est
entre mes deux oreilles
gelly as moi l'expression une [ __ ] de
fiches excellent je m'étais mis au
service de l'économie ultra financiarisé
des sociétés en bourse pour lesquelles
je travaille et je n'avais plus qu'une
chose chose en tête croissance
exponentielle rentabilité à deux
chiffres rapport trimestriel
et tous ceux qui l'accompagnent il n'a
pas fallu longtemps d'éloignement de mon
rêve pour que j'explose envol et c'est
là que je me suis retrouvée
sur ce lit d'hôpital mais peu je
m'attendais à vivre une autre expérience
une expérience de mort imminente
à ce moment là je me sais absorbé dans
un instinct espace obscur sombre mais il
ne fait pas peur parce que dans cet
espace il ya tous n'ont pas besoin de
manifester 3 que ce soit puisque tout
est dans le lot manifester et là une
voix me parle une fois que je pourrais
très bien et cette fois me dit hyper et
du fier de ce que tu as à promener avec
ces mots le film de même dans cet espace
où tout est vérité une seule réponse non
et la voix ne s'arrête pas là elle
répond crois tu que tu est sur le chemin
pour le plq et deux nuls sur l'année
crois tu que tu est sur le chemin pour
le fait que donner même scénario le film
de ma vie la même réponse évidente du
tout et j'ai vite et non à ce moment là
je me fais absorbé dans un trou béant de
désarroi ultime
je lève la tête j'appelle la voix et
jeudi mais carrément chemin comme un
enfant du bluff et à ça elle ne répond
juste troubles on va approcher la gueule
et je me retrouve sur le lit d'hôpital à
cet instant à cet instant précis je sais
que je vais m'en sortir
à cet instant précis je sais que ma vie
va changer à jamais mais la seule chose
que je cherche c'est une lueur d'espoir
parce que je ne sais pas comment je vais
faire sortir de ce trou béant que des
emplois dans le nejm aux essais tenus en
espoirs c'est un homme s'appelle martin
l'énigme l'année je me retrouve un jour
dans une conférence comme celle là est
leur cali est docteur en physique de la
complicité
docteur en histoire docteur en
philosophie et qui plus est
prospectiviste économique internationale
de prendre la main et là il nous
explique comment depuis un certain
nombre d'années
vingt ans il a travaillé avec des
scientifiques avec des érudits de
poutine ils ont réussi à prouver que
l'on peut modéliser mathématiquement les
cycles qui influencent l'histoire de
l'humanité il existe plusieurs sites
dont certains macro cycle de cinq cent
cinquante ans à chaque fois qu'un cycle
arrive à sa fin une rupture majeure
fenêtre
aussi une vie sauf qu'aujourd'hui ce que
nous vivons n'est pas une crise c'est la
fin de saison de l'une de ses cibles
maigrin fait majeur dans l'histoire
connue de l'humanité nous ne vivons pas
une rupture mais cinq rupture une
rupture économique et rupture écologique
les ruptures technologiques une rupture
philosophie et ruptures organisationnel
structurelles on nous dit ce n'est pas
une crise que nous vivons maintenant
changement de part m
et à cet instant il nous montre cette
image que je vous montre ici il nous dit
désormais vous avez juste tout choix le
premier choix qui vont vous c'est de
regarder le monde avec des lunettes
rouges et vous avez toutes les raisons
du monde du pessimisme
puisque vous allez crever à l'époque
logique soit sinon vous avez la
possibilité de regarder le monde avec
des lunettes et vous avez toutes les
raisons du monde d'être optimiste
puisque vous allez être porté par une
logique en d'un printemps qui portera
l'humanité pendant cinq cent cinquante
ans à cet instant marc halévy ne parle
pas 400 personnes qui sont dans la
chambre il ne reparle cas - et je
comprends que tout est une question de
posture m'ont dit naviguer du pessimisme
extrême de la traite de sombrer à
nouveau à l'optimisme nécessaire de me
dire je vais en sortir plus pega la vie
à l'espoir
ce jour là j'ai fait un choix j'ai
décidé que plus jamais je ne porterais
ses lunettes et j'ai décidé qu'à partir
de là je n'ai pas la soirée et que je
dédierai le restant de mes jours de mon
existence de ma carrière à ce changement
de paradigme pour que j'arrête d'oeuvrer
pour une économie qui ne met que
l'argent au centre que l'individualisme
la peur est que je puisse oeuvrer pour
une économie qui met au centre lui mène
la vie
le partage est oui à l'entreprise l'un
mauron
à cet instant il s'est passé plein de
choses j'ai fait beaucoup beaucoup de
choses
donc j'ai investi dans des astéries
start up pour comprendre la culture
numérique
certaines aujourd'hui sens par nature
j'ai développé des programmes de
bien-être avec danger
on a développé on aurait fait rien tout
seul
nous avons développé des programmes pour
le bien-être entreprises 4500
entreprises
on a travaillé avec des dirigeants
d'entreprise des sociétés dans la
prévention d'une opulente séparés à des
milliers de personnes etc etc et
aujourd'hui je me disais qu'est ce que
je fais je le raconte toutes ces choses
je fais une de ses corvettes
d'inspiration et ça ce n'est pas juste
non parce que peu importe ce que nous
avons fait peu importe ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui encore le monde a besoin de
beaucoup d'efforts pour qu'ils chargent
donc cela me paraît assez et du coup je
me suis dit ce que je vais faire je vais
partager avec vous trois pépites du
changement de paradigme la première
pépite
c'est que j'ai appris grâce à marc
halévy c'est que il faut oser le jeu du
jour de ma naissance au jour de ma mort
la seule présence qui sera tout le temps
avec moi c'est moi
alors ne me fait pas croire que
m'occuper de moi c'est être égoïste
narcissique gothique et tous ces noms
d'oiseaux que l'on donne aux différentes
personnes qui par l'enjeu si je reste
bloqué là dedans je suis d'abord mais le
jeu n'est pas là dedans l'objectif est
de poser le jeu pourquoi pour oser un
dornier pas majeur
mon avec aujourd'hui car si tu veux être
un grand dirigeant qui devait être un
bon manager observe autour de croix
rouge des pièces influence et dynamique
systémique et s'ils sont atteints
davantage tu seras un grand leader bull
shit tous nos problèmes sont à
l'intérieur de nous jamais on avait dit
qu'il fallait que je regarde ça le
regarde avec stephen hill tous les
fautifs sont parlants font la une
immense majorité presque 99 29 % des
problèmes que j'ai dans ma vie je les ai
à l'intérieur je les cultive et je
l'aimé fuite
à partir de là j'apprends qu'il faut que
je regarde à l'intérieur que je
travaille les fêlures et que j'aille
voir ce miroir où je suis complètement à
poil devant lequel je ne peux pas me
déguiser comme je fais
la vie de tous les jours vous l'aurez
compris dans ce chemin je fais quoi
le premier changement de paradigme seul
passage de nego système vers un éco
système
parce que dans ce passage là j'apprends
à grandir et comme j'ai grandi je
reconnais que je suis emparé d'individus
dans mes deux femmes qui eux aussi ont
défendu rick eux aussi cherchent à caen
gay est un vrai leader grandit pour
aider les autres à grandir et c'est là
qu'on rentre dans l'ouverture du je au
nous deuxième pépite de ce changement de
paradigme où l'on va demander vivi
dualiste vers le monde de partage
et quoi de plus beau dans le partage que
de vivre une aventure humaine partager
ensemble cet esprit qui nous rassemble
alors je vais vous parler d'une formule
qui est la pierre philosophale
vous ferez à picorer cette formule et
vous touche vous transformerez and en se
touchant dans notre groupe pro et perso
quelle est cette formule celle de la
dynamique des groupes de gros pour nous
a toujours dit pour qu'il fonctionne il
doit produire ce projet d et il doit
avoir un lien affectif ce travail là
pour donner du sens aucun super mais
quand on creuse la question sur quand il
faut beaucoup plus que ça pour avoir du
sens où il faut que ce sens sont alignés
avec une raison des arrêts comme
pourquoi des charriers père médecin vous
avez aller loin mais ça va plus loin
parce que le nez de son magnifique
jarrah a prises dans cette fabuleuse
industrie de la vis c'est qu'en plus du
sens il faut de l'identité identité
c'est ce qui fait que vous êtes fiers de
vos couleurs
l'identité ce sont nos valeurs notre
raison d'être vole culture votre île de
vie ce qui fait que vous vous
reconnaissez
ce qui fait que vous avez envie de faire
des choses ensemble ce qui fait que
certaines personnes pour arriver à faire
ça cette adoration le dos le logo de
leur entreprise
et ça c'était monnaie courante dans
notre industrie
on a envoyé un bac et les baies qui
venait d'en faire une compétition jamais
des salariés qui fait ce qui était
peut-être avec des lots à notre avis du
ce n'est pas cette entreprise et ça fait
bien penser la laiterie bonus un très
bel exemple
bref mais qui vient tout contact s'est
tatoué son logo vertueux c'est trop tard
et il a déjà fait qui est plus dans nos
profs d'engagement pour son travail
peut-il y avoir que ce volant qui s'est
tatoué le coup à l'épaule ou coup ça
c'est la preuve de la puissance de
l'identité vous comprenez bien j'ai pas
en train de vous dire de vous taper la
carte de visite sur le torse
c'est juste pour illustrer la puissance
de l'identité à ces gens là car il
venait je me disais vous on m'a fait la
province l'a déjà fait donc ça fait un
gros budget marketing et je les gages et
de cadeaux je me dirai au moins tu seras
mon temps plus long temps de prendre au
conducteur
mais ce n'est pas suffisant identité
parce que la wiesmann corps a pris une
autre leçon quand j'ai commencé dans
cette industrie personne ne pariait un
kopeck pour ma carrière mais moi j'ai
douté de pouvoir payer mes factures en
travaillant dans l'industrie du surf
pourtant aujourd'hui elle pèse soit 5
milliards d'euros dans le monde et
j'étais loin d'imaginer que je pourrais
gagner aussi bien m
grâce au sol mais pourquoi ça marche
parce que nous étions deux grands
dirigeants d'entreprises hyper
intelligent de grands stratèges et de
secours du malheur mais la vie est une
chose
on avait un rêve
et ce rêve nous voulions le partager on
voulait que le plus grand nombre de
personnes au monde puisse connaître la
magnifique divinité je dirais presque de
vivre en communion avec la nature grâce
à une planche et des millions de
personnes ont subi notre vin et c'est ça
qui a fait le succès de notre industrie
les plus grands de cette industrie ne
savait avons rénové ils ont juste se
contenter de vivre et partager semaine
mais ce n'est pas tout parce qu'il ne
suffit pas de rêver encore faut-il que
nos rêves deviennent réalité qui sans
grade en la matière et conçoit a perdu
dans ces espaces qu'utopique et
qu'engendra d'un rêve dans la réalité
la dernière partie de la formule il faut
que je laisse
avec une belle action symbolique pour
marquer le rêve devenu réalité
oui à ce moment là on est conscient
qu'on arrivait et on l'a fait on dit
souvent surfer alors c'est un peu
inconscient collectif qui imagine sa
tête après on faisait juste fait il rêve
devenu réalité après comme le cros vie
était un rêve on faisait la fête
alors qu'est ce qui fait que nous
n'allons pas faire mon rêve qu'est ce
qui fait que l'on rêve liens restent pas
passer moi la deuxième dépression ses
murs qu'on se trouve face à lokeren est
composé des briques de nos peurs nos
d'autres le complexe nautique certitude
aux croyances limitantes ces murs qui
nous empêchent d'avancer ce qui nous
apporte toutes les excuses au monde pour
le ballet vers leurs fringues mais quand
vous commencez à appliquer ces deux
changements par année que vous commencez
à regarder vers l'intérieur commencé à
grandir à vous même que vous commencez à
accompagner le groupe pour que lui-même
ensemble pour puissiez vous élevez vous
allez aller tellement beau qu'il
n'existe plus aucun mur que vous ne
puissiez gravir
vous verrez qu'il n'existe aucun mur au
monde qu'ils ne puissent pas être
surpassée et à ce moment là vous
comprenez que vous avez beau avoir ces
briques devant le nez vous arrêtez de
les voir parce que vous savez que
guerrilla ses briques
il y à votre avenir derrière ces briques
il y a votre rêve devenu réalité et tous
ensemble sur le groupe ce sublime
inoculant faire péter en mille morceaux
ses briques pour aller saisir la
véritable magnificience de cette
aventure humaine partage sa slam pour
mun lapierre philosophique de la
dynamique des mondes et quand un groupe
se sublime à lui-même et grandit
naturellement verbois versa
de conscience de son appartenance à un
écosystème à l'environnement à cet
instant là on rentre dans la troisième
pépite de ce changement de paradigme où
soudainement on devient inconscient
entre empreinte dans le monde et qu'elle
va t'elle être son rating positive
négative car je commence à intéresser à
ça je découvre une étude scientifique
complètement moderne un groupe de
bonhomme qui décide se dissoudre et ce
qui nous est possible d'influencer une
population juste pas l'intention pour
être sûr de bien calculer le truc qui
sont partis même guerre du liban à
beyrouth où sera sa mère ou de personnes
nous disent les gars on va envoyer de la
paix et de l'amour dans les zones en
conflit en pleine guerre et on va voir
ce qui se passe au bout de l'ain ils ont
réussi à prouver qu'il avait une
corrélation positive chaque fois qu'ils
se réunissaient il y avait une chute
très importante des violence des combats
des agressions mais pas de 1 2 point
pour cent que l'on pouvait batailler
soit un demi pour cent
ça ça vous donne en sont ces deux ans
parce que les mecs parlent pas content
du résultat qui était déjà exceptionnel
s'il atteint comme bien demande devons
nous être pour influencer une population
de quelle taille racine carrée %
c'est-à-dire que si ici nous sommes
aujourd'hui 100 personnes et que nous
sommes ce groupe là ça veut dire que
nous sommes racine carrée de 1 % d'une
population égale sans quelle est la
taille de cette population pour enlever
la cigarette je fais le café 200 x 110
mille 6000 cas plus la racine carrée
égale à 1% comme tu es donc c'est un bon
sens et mille fois saints un suivi de
6,0 à nous un million de personnes
ça veut dire que si aujourd'hui je vous
avais dit de nous mettre ensemble et
d'envoyer une intention de paix d'amour
dans notre entourage
ce soir même les vaches et les
coléoptères du département va faire
alors qu'est ce que je veux vous dire
par là le troisième changement par le
seco aussi petit que le groupe ne groupe
soit il il est possible de changer le
monde
alors moi ce que je voulais vous amener
à ça au seul endroit que nous répond de
rejoindre depuis que nous sommes tout
petits
/ amy il existe le monde me journaux et
je les ai vécus pendant 15 ans n'est pas
une fois j'ai très très bien payé pour
surfer les plus beaux moments des
vallées les plus belles montagnes
règlement ce no more et comme j'étais
nuance quand personne me demander quoi
que ce soit parce que c'était les autres
qui travaillent à ma place
c'était possible jamais je n'aurais
imaginé que je peux dire ça langlement
de bisounours et qui ce n'est jamais
quelque chose sous sites à une seule
personne au monde qui ne le connaîtra
jamais celui qui ferme la porte qui
donne accès en disant qu'il existera et
au bout de tout ce parcours je vous ai
donné les 3 petits changements de
paradigme je me retourne je me retrouve
genou départ sur mon lit d'hôpital
juste après l'expérience de mon mieux
j'ai un beau la seule question qui
vaille c'est quoi mon bonheur est là la
réponse est claire aucun abeilles un
lecteur à lui seul de leurs gorges du
symbolique coucher dessus j'ai mon plein
rose et vert nous éduquer à la copine de
mama à la mamie de ma copine 0 un livre
ça va être un pocket à 5 euros
mon chat et les gens que j'aime où était
passé de mes ambitions de carrière
la course patrimoniale manquant d'un
membre qui déborde où était passé
la ici et maintenant dans celui de vidal
je sais que mon bonheur
alors c'est tout ce que je vous ai ras
bol vous rajoutez la simplicité nous
reste l'unique seule chose à faire nous
poser la question car nous faire avec la
magnifique ville blanche s'étend devant
nous parce que nous avons deux points
restent classées surface et regarder les
cinq dupuis ramener le mans de là où
elles vont l'amener et le gaz
d'échappement éventuellement n'avoir que
nos yeux rouges ou décidé de nous lever
de porter de lunettes hâte de commencer
à voir le monde différemment et
comprendre encore aujourd'hui peu
importe tout ce qui a été fait peu
importe ce que je vous raconte ça n'a
pas été suffisant mais ce qui sûr que ça
nous plaise ou pas nous sommes la
génération du changement
nous allons devoir le vivre en dépit de
notre volonté le coup de pied dans les
fesses sur la prière blanche dans le
vide alors que de vous prêts il suffit
d'une question posture si vous êtes
prêts à me suivre
si vous prêt à vous suivre parce qu'on a
encore besoin de beaucoup de monde s'est
passé a été fait pour aller vers un
monde aux primaires m l'épanouissement
le bonheur et je le souligne surtout à
morand
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]